non
par exemple imagine que tu puisses avoir
quelque chose en plus en plus en plus
tous préfèrent avoir donné deux sets 6/3
je crois que jacques préféré que j'ai
deux sexes de ces imagine que tu sois
enceinte de nouveau oui d'essence soit
désires tu fais une échographie et on te
dit voilà votre petit mais il a deux
sexes il a donné où il ya trois yeux
qu'est ce que tu ferais tu te rapporter
ou tu le garderais parce que finalement
ces cas là c'est comme ça je regarderai
pas tu viendrais pas tu fais comme
hitler alors dire que tu les gens qui
sont pas normaux qua non je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le moment on allait les
moyens d'empêcher un être d'avoir une
vie vraiment défavorisés utiliser ses
moyens
tu rentres chez toi soir et tu trouves
jacques dutronc au lit avec isabelle
adjani mettant joyeux où tu appelles
paris match je me joins à eux
immédiatement moi je n'ai rien contre
les amours saphiques alors salaires dans
ces conditions la wii avec isabelle
adjani ça va oui oui la condition vous
séparer avec jacques ceci ce triste ou
séparé le pouf thomas il se retrouve
tout seul
pourquoi il serait sensation 76 enfin
moi tout le monde se sépare il faut le
confier à quelqu'un ça je hais ce que tu
préférais qu'il soit confié à karen
cheryl à chantal goya ou à dorothée
c'est un régime strict reviennent
je ne sais pas du tout je suis à toi sa
mère nourricière à qui voudrait du thé
soit confiée mais je prends je profite à
chantal goya parce que c'est la seule
que je connaisse des temps m c'est la
seule king des enfants ouais saviez la
télé en plus chantal goya donc elle ce
qui pourrait du moins c'est pour ça
enfin je crois qu'il faudrait surtout le
monde et invite thomas en l'occurrence à
dos
je crois qu'il préférait se passer
maintenant je vais poser une question
encore plus con c'est possible tu es
prisonnière et les gens qui te tiennent
comme ça géôliers t'oblige à faire
l'amour avec un animal terrible s'est
jamais pensé tu vas y penser pour la
première fois ce soir il était temps à
ton âge est ce que tu préfèrerais un
cochon est un cochon on verra un cochon
un chien ou anam bien tout en temps tu
peux réfléchir en haletant là vraiment
c'est quand même moins bien qu isabelle
adjani ah bah oui c'est autre chose que
la ville réserve à taiwan cède pas
j'aime beaucoup les lannoy sont sa
trémie mais bon c'est bien c'est les
accords avaient appelé à dutronc banda
alors maintenant si tu devais dîner avec
quelqu'un t'a pas le choix je suis
obligé dîner avec lui tu as pas d'autre
solution
tu préfèrerais dîner avec un sourd muet
ou avec un aveugle bègue
gj bien
l'aveuglent bec mais ce que je pourrais
partir bon dernière question aux comptes
françoise hardy oui quel fabuleux
c'est une question à l'ajax